all right we've got natalie brunell here
with us thank you so much for doing this
thanks so much for having me i'm so
excited all right uh you just quit your
job so congratulations on that right
another person
[Applause]
another person quitting their job to go
full-time to work on bitcoin which by
the way bitcoin just crossed 55 000 not
saying it's because the show's on but
you know maybe it is tell us one why did
you quit and then we'll talk about what
you're gonna do next yeah so i've worked
in legacy tv news for over 10 years and
just in the same way that
decentralization is hitting finance i
think it's also hitting media i mean you
guys are making this show right um and i
just feel like i've been reporting for
the last 10 years on the front lines in
the trenches on some of the biggest
crises facing our country and when you
learn about bitcoin you start to connect
the dots that a lot of it has to do with
money and how broken our system is and
so i just got really passionate about
this space and i felt like there's a
huge gap in terms of financial literacy
in this country so i just i wanted to
help i want to educate people and i want
to spread the word talk to us about
going down the bitcoin rabbit hole
because i think we watched it like live
happen on twitter this started as like i
think you heard about bitcoin then i
think you read the bitcoin standard and
then it was just like you fell off a
cliff deep down in the rabbit hole and
then there was a podcast then all of a
sudden i saw you started interviewing
all these people i was like what is
going on who is this person but like
walk us through that journey of actually
discovering bitcoin and like how you got
kind of orange built yeah so i've
actually had bitcoin since 2017. i was
working at a station up in sacramento in
the state capital of california and um
heard about bitcoin because i was dating
a guy who knew someone at coinbase and
all the guys were talking about bitcoin
and crypto i was like what is this and i
really regret not learning more about it
then because obviously i would have a
lot more right now but i bought a little
um and then i really started going down
the rabbit hole when the pandemic hit
like markets crashed i think everyone
sort of realized is this the fourth
turning things are never going back to
the way they were and i just started
consuming all the literature all the
youtube videos all the education online
i could read the bitcoin standard
multiple times read a bunch of books and
i was like hooked and i decided to turn
my podcast which i i had been
interviewing people about their lives
and success stories it was called career
stories i decided to just pivot focus
solely on bitcoin interview the legends
including yourself and learn more about
why you guys have this conviction and
it turned into something i didn't even
expect i left my job you've interviewed
a whole bunch of people michael saylor
all the way on down what are the biggest
lessons that you've learned from
actually doing the interviews like what
are the takeaways for you yeah and my
claim to fame is also having peter
schiff admit that he should have bought
bitcoin which is awesome
you know it's just been fascinating to
see how how different everybody's
backgrounds are you know everyone comes
from some people humble beginnings some
people have this you know massive
investment background
but ultimately everyone realized that
there's something wrong in our system in
our economic money printing society that
we live in and bitcoin is the solution
it's the sort of life raft that can fix
a lot of the problems that are facing
this this country in the world um so
it's just interesting to see everyone's
like transformation down the rabbit hole
and how how much we all have in common
right we all come from different
backgrounds but ultimately we want to
help empower people we feel like
the system shouldn't be rigged against
us and and i think that this provides
financial freedom and access for
everybody i think that's amazing
now when you quit you didn't just quit
just to go do the podcast you're gonna
continue to do the podcast uh but also
you are gonna go create this training
program for women in this entire
community around uh women joining the
bitcoin community let's first talk about
there's not a lot of women right uh if i
go on twitter and i look at my twitter
feed not a lot of women uh when i go and
i say hey who should we bring on as
guests on the show there's just not a
lot of women to choose from and so uh
it's very obvious i think our youtube
audience is like 94
male uh and that's across the world
right so what is the issue or like how
do you identify like why is it so male
dominant versus uh having more of a
balance of like 50 50 men and women yeah
i mean i don't really know the exact
reasons but if you just look at the the
world of finance in general and
investing it's predominantly male driven
um and i think that there was some
really interesting surveys that were put
out recently by blockfi and other
companies saying women know about
cryptocurrency they even acknowledge
that the price is going to go up in the
next five years but they just feel
hesitant and they're not willing to
invest in it or they don't feel like
they understand it enough so i feel like
we need to change that right because
bitcoin is for everyone we need to get
all sorts of people involved and i think
that the gender gap really needs to to
decrease so um that's you know something
that i really want to do i want to bring
more girls in i want to get the girl
memes going
um and you know create like a sorority
in a community where women can like
network and and have their voices
uplifted in this space so you're
creating a training program for those
that don't know uh we've been we being
myself and a couple other folks have
been training as many people as we
possibly can in bitcoin and crypto uh
it's almost all men uh unfortunately and
what we've been doing is uh doing that
in the way that one we can get them
educated with two try to help them get
jobs uh we're gonna help you and you've
put together an entire curriculum it's
way better than ours
just because you actually have uh the
skill set to do it and talk to us about
this program in terms of like what women
who go through it are actually going to
get out of it yeah so this is not just
learning about bitcoin like fundamentals
of bitcoin and sort of how bitcoin
empowers um societies around the globe
but it's also the history of money it's
the history of our economic system
starting from the very beginning when we
had barter all the way to fiat
government money um when the federal
reserve was you know invented when we
went off the gold standard all of that
so we cover a huge amount of information
but it's very interactive um we have
five days a week of events discussion
groups social things question and
answers and we have amazing coaches we
have an amazing guest panel of some of
the most successful women in the space
and again we just want to provide a
community for women where they can
engage with one another where they feel
like it's a safe welcoming space not
that you know twit bro twitter is not
welcoming but you know just a place
where women can see it as an entry point
to start to network and engage with each
other share ideas maybe connect for
future job opportunities and just learn
about bitcoin and our monetary system
and be able to also like articulate the
message to their own communities
so when you think about uh women going
through this program well the part to me
that's so fascinating is like one you
can learn but two is the community right
and i just put in the chat i said you
know if you're a guy watching this go
tell your wife your girlfriend your
female friend a stranger at the store
like we need as many women in this
industry as possible how do you think
about the community aspect of that and
like why that's so important well i
think women in general we're so
community driven we love sort of the
idea of sharing things and being a part
of something bigger and so i think
that's like the most important element
because you can go online by yourself
right you can watch a bunch of youtube
videos that's what i spent basically all
my free time over the last year doing i
read all the books but there's something
to be said about being able to engage
and interact live with other people who
might have the same questions as you or
maybe you learn from their questions
maybe you meet someone who becomes a
lifelong friend maybe they connect you
to someone in crypto that ends up
getting you a job but we're all just
like we're learning from each other and
i think connection is one of the best
things in this space which is growing so
quickly and i think there's a great
opportunity to bring more people in one
thing also is your family's not from
america and i think that one of the most
interesting parts of this is like many
immigrants to the united states uh have
this almost like cognitive dissonance
right you live in a western world
country where there's great
infrastructure uh if i go to the atm for
the most part unless the banks being
stupid they give me my money uh and sure
we can complain all day about the banks
but like the currency is somewhat stable
and they're somewhat good services
that's not true around
a good portion of the world so talk a
little bit about your family kind of
coming here and like how that plays into
your interest in bitcoin yeah so my
family came here for the american dream
they didn't come here to necessarily be
you know rich like jeff bezos and have a
yacht and all that but they just wanted
you know a nice house the middle class
life a vacation for their kids good
schools um and you know for me i've
tweeted before that bitcoin is now my
american dream because i feel like over
the last
20 years since we've been in this
country um things have just gotten
harder and harder my family lost
everything in the financial crisis they
are representative of the people out
there who you know have always held most
of their assets in like cash or savings
accounts they they don't know
necessarily how to invest and they they
see the stock market as something risky
they couldn't afford you know a big
house that's going to appreciate and
value so you know i see them as the
little guy and i all the people i've
reported on and interviewed over the
last 10 years i see the little guy and i
see the little guy constantly getting
screwed and i think that there needs to
be something done where you
give the power back to them to be able
to work for their money and then not
have it lose value let let it you know
go into your bank account and appreciate
like let you you know plan for the
future be able to save for the future so
that you can take care of your family
that's what's really important to me
because that's like that's my family in
a nutshell they they're good people
they've always followed the rules paid
their taxes like they should be able to
keep their money and not have it like
depreciate in value every year just by
having it in the bank when you think of
a woman going through a program like
this i think there's people who say okay
they'll learn about bitcoin maybe
they'll go buy bitcoin there's going to
be a community they can talk about
things that maybe they they're
uncomfortable talking about on twitter
or whatever uh but also there's this
element of like uh almost
female empowerment around finances
totally and i always uh talk to polina
about this of like
uh i think it's
beyonce maybe i forget who says it but
somebody's like like if you want to
change the way the world looks like give
money to women and then like get the
[ __ ] out of their way basically yeah
right and if you do that like it
completely changes the way that assets
get allocated investments get made
people naturally like you invest in
people that have some more experiences
to you that look more like you and
things like that so talk through a
little bit of like what you see the
impact being yeah i mean i agree i've
even heard those stories of you know
like giving the micro loans to women in
underprivileged you know global
economies and they uplift their
community because they now can make
financial decisions and i just think
that there's something so special about
empowering women they have so much
purchasing power in our country i've
been reading all these stats you know
putting together the training materials
and it's like women make up the majority
of home purchases they make up the
majority of consumer spending they have
like 40 trillion dollars in um in
consumer spending behind them so you
know why aren't they investing more why
don't they feel comfortable with crypto
we have to give them an environment
where they feel empowered and feel like
they understand it they can communicate
with one another and the way girls
communicate with another with one
another and i just think it's super
exciting yeah i mean a lot of women want
to make smart decisions they just need
to be given that education and that
confidence and i think that this space
is going to be 50 50 before we know it
like i'm really excited about you want
to hear something wild that a lot of
people don't like to admit so i just uh
at uh galzara
on in the youtube chat just reminded me
of this uh mike green
wife made him buy bitcoin jason calcanis
wife made him buy bitcoin i actually
think jason can his wife bought the
bitcoin and he didn't and when everyone
was somebody he's like hey you are uh
you're negative against bitcoin you're a
bear on bitcoin it's like no no my wife
owns some yeah like like that's always
like his defense and so i do think that
there's an entire portion of the
industry that just like nobody really
knows about like nobody talks about it
they're not on twitter or whatever and
so uh the the uh gauzera in uh the
youtube chat said my wife maybe buy it
too so like there's this element i think
that kind of uh gets played out here
that a lot of folks uh um don't really
talk about right yeah and we're not risk
averse i think women actually take
really big risks and in fact when i
heard about you know bitcoin from the
guy i was dating his his friend was at
coinbase i ended up buying more bitcoin
than the guy i was dating i was like oh
i believe in this like i'm all in
so yeah i know i think i think there's a
lot of women that are excited about this
they just need you know the tools and
the information